i love
learning about the behind the scenes of
the making of a movie things that maybe
you don't read in the press notes people
things that people have not heard about
what do you think would people would be
surprised to learn
about the making of jungle cruise i mean
i'd love to talk about
the amazonian village that we built in
kauai we couldn't go to the amazon
i think our director would have loved to
have filmed in the amazon so we filmed
on this
on thousands of acres on this reservoir
this extraordinary amazonian village and
actually
so much of the film was shot practically
in that way like we were it's tactile
you can touch it and
i think that was really important to us
there's been a few iterations of this
script that has gone around hollywood
and there were a few other people who
were attached to it uh over the past
decade or two
but once you start really digging into
the script when we did
with our writer michael green as well as
jama
you really start to realize
why it's taken so long for this movie to
get made
because of the careful consideration
because of the
multiple nuances across the board
because of the
care and reverence you had to show the
ride
when you think about the amazon and you
think about the
culture of the amazon and the culture of
brazil
there's just so many nuanced details
that
really went into uh the development of
this and then the execution of it
and as emily was saying we were down in
hawaii we shot down there we also shot
in sound stage two as well
um but it was really really
extraordinary and so when you go into
something like this and i've been around
the block emily's been around the block
uh but when you when all the elements
are placed on the table in front of you
between the brand of disney her career
my career
jama colette who comes from a
a line of filmmakers spanish filmmakers
who are very very talented but yet
this was really his big breakout in
terms of building a world
so many elements involved that really
made you sit back and like go wow like
it sat you down
you just had to pause and like really
take our time every day and i think when
you watch the movie then you'll see all
these
details and nuance and specificity to it
uh that really come alive and certainly
with our chemistry too that was another
big thing
that was really the anchor and if we
didn't get along
which we [ __ ] hate each other and
very
very good actor but we're very good
actors